2017 nfl offensive player of the year
now in his first season with the atlanta
falcons running back todd gurling he's
here thanks to pillsbury and the welcome
home project welcome to the program todd
how are you pal
i'm doing great man thanks for having me
on you've been welcome
home sort of back to georgia where you
went to college how does it feel to be
back where you played for the bulldogs
um
it feels great man it definitely feels
great and i think that's that's the
whole point of it um to be able to just
to come back home um being able to
to partner up with pillsbury and
operation home front to to help bring
military families
you know back home give them a home
and help them transition into
regular civilian life so
i think that's just the whole thing and
just being me being able to just come
back to georgia you know not only being
able to feel home on the field but like
off the field being able to get back
into the community
um you know play for the city of atlanta
and think about you know just doing
stuff in the community and just giving
back
what has stood out the most to you so
far during this first season with the
falcons
um
just i mean
it's just been a you know a weird year
first of all you know obviously with
with the you know the pandemic and you
have the election then you have the
season
season not going well like we thought it
was at the beginning but
um you know being able to pick things up
and then being able to still try to do
my stuff you know off the field
um you know i obviously can't really do
much stuff hands-on
obviously
so
it's it's been
i've been it's been gone it's been going
well it's been going well we got the
holidays coming up so
i'm excited about that you know being
able to just you know not only see
myself with my family and my friends but
my teammates and
and and everyone around you know the
nation especially after the year we had
so
um
that's why i was just happy just like
happy just to be able to just do the
stuff that i'm doing you know be able to
provide
um brittany and trevor
um and that son noah a new home you know
being able for them to be able to have
have a place to be at to to feel welcome
to just to feel home and
you know there's nothing nothing better
than that didn't have that during these
times especially during the holiday tell
me a little bit more about how and why
you got involved with that welcome home
project
um
it goes back to like i said being able
to to come back to georgia the state of
georgia um not only try to you know make
a statement on the field but just to try
to make a statement off um
there's so much so much things that need
to be done in this world and you know
a great city of atlanta and to be able
to
be a fan of pillsbury my whole life and
you know be able to partner up with them
um never in a million years i would
would have thought of an opportunity
like this to be able to to help someone
and provide them you know with a home so
i just want to say thank you to
pillsbury operation home front for being
able to get me involved in
um you know to the community
to the state of georgia the city of
atlanta
uh you know just to represent something
you know bigger than myself not only
it's not even about me it's about
you know um you know trevor and brittany
you know for them to be happy them to
feel home
and you know i wouldn't have it any
other way than just just to keep doing
the stuff that i'm doing
um you know little by little one by one
and just thankful for for pillsbury for
being able to not only provide me with
this opportunity but to provide the
military family you know with the
opportunity to be in a a
home a brand new home at that
i'm going to take you to a place where
you definitely have become at home in
recent years and that's on the football
field you mentioned that the falcons
started off slowly three and four three
and one excuse me over the last four
games however when do you think things
turned in the falcons direction what was
the moment
um
when i messed up that um detroit game
and scored
you know we figured out
we figured out
we were we were a lot closer than women
in that game than we were on the other
one so
um we just got it together we got it
together i think everybody just really
got tired of
being in those same situations even
though we still try to make those
situations come up but
we're more comfortable now we know how
to finish those games we've been in
those games and
it was more just like enough is enough
we know what we have we know what we
what we what we can and we can't do and
everyone just needed to step up
you know it's it's in every running
backs instinct to get to the end zone it
almost felt like there was a magnet just
pulling you how how
what what are you experiencing in that
moment as you try to slam on the brakes
and avoid breaking the front end of the
goal line
um
clumsiness
you know
the way i fell it was just like slow
almost like roll my ankle um
yeah man just just as a football player
especially as a running back just kind
of just really just doing my job
knowing the situation but
just going through the whole
um trying to still run hard and protect
myself you know i didn't want to just
try to go through their
tiptoeing and then you know somebody
blast me now i'll be out for the game
but
um you know it was a learning experience
you know as many many situations as as
i've been in in four minutes and been
down i don't went down
you know it can go on the opposite end
as well so you know
i'm glad that happened um we've we've
definitely been able to be a better team
from that not only from that but
just from every you know loss that we we
dealt with this year you've got nine
games done your bi week is upon us
you're averaging just about 18 carries a
game what's your ideal workload at this
point i guess that
i got i guess that man so
um you know it's been some tough yards
we've been we've been trying to get
things done you know trying to get in
the end zone
um
but trying to help matt up help the pass
game out so
body's feeling good just got to get
myself right and get ready for the game
you know
we got the next
i'm always fascinated by the comparisons
from quarterback one team to another
i know you've only been in atlanta half
a season but can you do you have a sense
of similarities differences between matt
ryan and jared goff
yeah
they both rich as hell
[Laughter]
um
i don't know man
i don't know quarterbacks are funny to
me bro they just like yeah good dudes
though matt you know somebody just sit
back and not just like laugh because
he's you know he's very demanding he's
very demanding and you know as he should
you know he's a guy he's been in the
league for for quite a while so
um and you know you just see the
difference between the age
of just the reactions between matt and
and golf you know golf's more laid back
he's chilly he's young i'm pretty sure
10 years from from now he's going to be
you know uh
very responding to the coaches as he is
with the players so um and then just
being comfortable and you got to prove
yourself in this league man you know
it doesn't happen overnight as you know
uh
you know it's year by year and for
someone to do you're gonna respect
someone
um or you're gonna look at someone
different
um definitely doing it ten years
compared to five you know so just gotta
be able to just
oh no man i don't know i just got the
rambling justin
you referred to the fact that they're
both rich as hell when you talk to other
running backs around the league is there
ever any like
you know i don't get it
these guys are making 30 million plus
per year we're the ones doing the dirty
work we're the ones busting our asses
and we've got to fight and scratch and
call just to get to 10 million per year
something's not right here you guys talk
about that
not really you understand our lane
we look
we're just happy that we got a job so we
ain't gonna complain about it
about that you you start worrying about
a little bit too much then you're gonna
be at the house and then you ain't
really gonna be making nothing so
um i blessed either way it goes man you
know
um
can't never count anyone else pockets
you have to um
you know just count your blessing
you know what makes you happy long as
you and your family are protected and
safe
and you know that's all that matters
and
you're right you do need to count your
own pocket and it's important to make
sure that everything's in your pocket
that should be in your pocket i haven't
seen an update on the question or not
the rams
have settled up with you and paid you
everything they owe you have you gotten
your check from them yet
yeah they got me right man june 2nd
come a couple months late but you know
better late than never i would say
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports